so secretary kerry thanks for
being with us uh i guess my first
question would be
being a former presidential candidate
yourself
what would you say to uh vice president
biden today
at this point in the race well i i i
would just say keep doing what you're
doing i think he's doing a terrific job
i think the vice president has put
forward an economic plan
uh you folks out there in las vegas have
been hard hit by
kobet itself a lot of uh people have
died particularly
seniors your economy is hurting it's one
of the
biggest hurts in the country uh and we
want to get back to people being able to
travel to the
industry that keeps las vegas humming
the way to get back there is to have a
plan to deal with covid
and vice president biden has put forward
a plan
donald trump has has completely run away
from presidential leadership he has lied
to americans about
the covet-19 he continues to lie even
now in his campaign
and he uses himself as an example that
does not fit
the average life of most people in
america so
um i think the folks in in nevada
understand that and i hope people go out
and vote early you're able to start this
saturday
go to it and help calm america down and
end the chaos presidency
right i mean obviously this this
election uh
a lot of focus on cobit 19.
what do you think the biden
administration
should do immediately or what what is
the administration what is the campaign
saying that that they're going to do
immediately
to you know make things
better well the vice president has put a
real plan on the table
he has laid out exactly what we need to
do what he will do as president united
states in order to deal with covet
and it begins with very simple things
like
not flaunting the idea of or criticizing
or mocking the idea of wearing masks
excuse me masks actually reduce a huge
percentage something like 70
78 of transmission is reduced by masks
so that's critical for americans because
we don't want our hospitals
overwhelmed we don't want millions of
people dying that didn't have to die
so i think trump has shown a real
callousness about that there's no plan
joe biden
is going to convene the major doctors
epidemiologists experts
help show america what really
can be done how it can be done he's
going to provide the equipment necessary
for all our health care workers
he's going to help to create a capacity
to open
up our economy but to do it with
tracking tracing
the contact tracing so we can actually
not be the worst country in the world or
the second worst country in the world
dealing with cogan
that's where we are today president
trump has made us not first in a good
way
but first as one of the worst countries
in the world
in the response and joe biden will be
the exact opposite of that
have you been affected by coven 19 or
have
or or know someone who's who's been
diagnosed i've lost friends
i've lost friends luckily knock on wood
uh
so far no members of our family have it
my one of my daughters is a critical
care physician working in the
icu and one of our hospitals in boston
and she's right on the front line we
think about her every day and all the
other workers are out there
so everybody is affected by the way yes
so many parents are struggling to
educate their kids at home
to try to make ends meet to pay the
bills stay in the house
if it's a reddit or they're paying a
mortgage they're just a lot of
challenges here and
president trump hasn't even been able to
cut a deal to
provide additional assistance to people
a great lawmaker
is not a deal maker right and where he
has made them they've been bad deals
well in the you know the the cares act
that was passed over the
over the spring you know we have
legislation that
is sitting in congress to help people
with payments and and
it is just sitting there um you know
that they are working on other things
um so i guess i would ask you from an
international perspective
you know the trump administration places
a lot of blame
on this pandemic on china uh
is this uh china's fault
and would the biden administration
put any um you know put any restrictions
in
place to um
[Music]
to you know punish china in any way
look there are reasons for everybody in
america to be concerned about what china
did
china is not blameless in its early
response because
in fact uh it was not as transparent as
people claimed and
there were problems in that but but the
problem
again president obama left
donald trump with a plan that had our
people
in china actually tracing coronavirus to
learn more about it
and president trump pulled those people
back out of the country
we gave up the seat we had at the table
in order to do that
and when president trump says he closed
down flights from china
in fact he because of loopholes allowed
45 000 additional people to come from
china and spread it around america
he knew as he said in his own words
to bob woodward on on a on a
recording he is recorded as saying i
knew this was a killer
it was committed it was transferred by
air and yes it affected children
but i wanted to play it down my friends
we need a president united states who
doesn't play things down because he's
afraid it's going to hurt
his numbers or his economy or his
re-election
we need a president who's going to
protect the american people and if we
had done
what we knew we could do back then every
expert has said we would have saved
tens of thousands of lives in our
country that's what a president is
supposed to do
joe biden has a plan to do that and
we need to uh we need to elect
responsible leadership
um moving to these you know
some of the peace deals that the trump
administration has announced recently
uh particularly in the middle east would
the bodine administration
continue to uphold those deals and is
this something that
uh you know joe biden um in kamala
harris support
absolutely joe biden and kamala have
both
welcomed the initiative of the united
arab emirates uae
they took the initiative they're the
ones who live in the region they're the
ones who get the flack if there is flack
and they had the courage to stand up and
do and to
actually sort of cement what had already
been a changing relationship with the
state of israel
but joe biden is is a very very
pro-israel there's a long record of
support for israel
the obama administration gave the
largest single military assistance
memorandum of understanding for 10 years
38 billion dollars with israel
and built the iron dome system that
saved
thousands of lives of israelis and
others
and so um i think it is very clear yes
it is a
good step but it is not the final step
it's not yet
what you need to finish there and um
obviously there's a lot more work to do
in terms of another international issue
we the biden campaign put out a
statement yesterday about
azerbaijan in armenia and obviously the
atrocities that have been going on there
we have
turkey involved iran sort of on the side
all these countries are sort of
you know looking we you know syria is
not too far away
what is the abiding administration going
to do about this
escalating problem in that region well
it's going to require
real personal diplomacy it's going to
require leadership in order to
quiet it down we are one of the parties
to
what's called the minsk process which
together with russia
uh is uh and france is supposed to be
helping to
prevent this kind of explosion from
taking place
it's partly the absence of the united
states and even
the um sort of wink and nod that has
come
from the uh the uh
from president trump that has allowed
some of this to run out of hand but not
exclusively it's being used as a proxy
as you said turkey is involved with
azerbaijan
russia has interests with both but very
close interests with armenia
and we have to get a ceasefire in place
as rapidly as possible
and then we have to move once again to
see
uh if we can get the parties to uh
accept what is one of the real and
frozen intractable
uh conflicts in the world but it takes
great diplomacy and there is very little
diplomacy being done regarding it
uh final question here um you know you
served
uh as secretary of state for four years
you of course were a long time senator
uh would you
accept a position in the biden harris
cabinet if
that does happen to uh be what the
american people choose
i have no idea of no speculation about
anything i just
you know that's that's uh not what we're
here for we're here to elect
president biden uh and and that is
something that i think is sort of the
game that gets played in washington that
just doesn't have a place in the
campaign right now
do you have any specific message for the
people in
nevada in las vegas particularly about
why joe biden should be their pick
instead of president trump
look i loved being in nevada and
campaigned hard there and uh we've
in the last years president obama and
vice president biden have been
greatly appreciated by uh folks out
there i think that if you look at this
campaign
matters interests getting nevada back to
work uh putting people in a place where
their lives are going to be able to come
back together where covent is being
responsibly dealt with where we have a
president who will unite the country
not divide it uh not play to the lowest
common denominator of politics which are
racial divisions and other kinds of
of uh you know demagogic uh
uh steps and words that have been used
uh joe biden is clearly a decent
person of great integrity uh who knows
how to bring people together across the
aisle
and major major uh economic entities in
the country have all said
he has the best plan to put people back
to work and rebuild our economy
so let's do it let's end the chaos
presidency
and put somebody uh reasonable in there
who can lead america
in the way that we all hope and expect
all right secretary kerry thanks so much
privilege to be with you you have a good
rest of your day